did he always have to travel to get to
yours and not know how to get back
or is he just casually asking for money
all the time
welcome back welcome back welcome
back this is what season 2 season two
this is what season two you know when
you know when you watch like a dope
series
and you think [ __ ] this is a great
cliffhanger i have to wait three more
months till the next season one year
till the next season bro
you know as well you know when um you
watch a dope series
i never really think about it well i've
only restarted thinking about the last
few years when you watch a dope series
and you're like [ __ ] i hope they get a
season two fam like
ozark every time i finish ozark i think
please get another season
ozark is one of the
greatest shows it's life it's crazy how
good those are live
ozarks live someone someone put on their
instagram you know when you when um
when you put on the the type of thing
where you have to say oh
give me what am i trying to say i don't
know g
you know when you have on instagram
where your people can ask you questions
that's what you
say and then they say one of the things
they said was oh can you recommend me a
series on netflix and i typed back ozark
and that was today
it's a phenomenal show jason bateman is
the next thing
he's the next guy he was a comedian you
know swear down
like he was doing like he used to do
like funny movies and stuff back in the
day oh you mean like yeah of course i
knew that kind of
yeah did you know he was on i've never
seen the show and i'm sure you've never
seen it as well but i know it's old he
was a child actor
okay he was on have you ever heard of
the show little house on the prairie
yeah everyone's heard of that
but no one knows what it actually is
it's just one of them old-timey shows
that everyone knows of
apparently he was on that no way he was
a kid no way yeah
do you know another everyone knows
that's a
what did you just say what was that an
old-timey movie but no one's ever
everyone knows but no one's actually
yeah so this is another fun fact
everyone knows but no one really knows
so you know the fun fact this is the fun
fact yeah sick
you know the the the tune my goal was to
party
a lot of people don't know that the
person that sang that song yep
was [ __ ] eddie murphy edward murphy
eddie murphy i only found that out like
last year
i found that out yesterday i played that
song like
four times on the bat just because of
that he can sing fun he can sang sang
he's he's a talented guy him and jamie
foxx are like
up there i'm so happy you said jamie
foxx
jb fox is tier one
male vocalist from jamie foxx is the
next thing when he used to do the sets
on his comedy shows
just piping up man ran out of material
just got the piano out fam
oh he's unpredictable album was such a
great album such a great jamie foxx is a
next level talent
ah what a guy he's an oscar winner right
hooray i'm sure
forward sorry ray the film range ray i'm
pretty sure you've won the oscar
or at least got nominated i'm not too
sure i thought you would have won it for
uh django i thought you want something
for zhang he might have won something
for django
i'm pretty sure so anyway he's yeah he's
either oscar winner or a multiple
nominated
he's he's one side next level singer
yeah next level comedian yeah
bro he can do it all he's a childish
gambino him in charge can be understood
him childish gambino and eddie murphy
clearly eddie murphy back to the point
eddie [ __ ] murphy black
people is what we're trying to get
artistes are full-fledged artists they
can do it all
they can do it all bro on top of your
because i like your fun facts segments
so much
i'm gonna do an intermittent segment i'm
not gonna put it in
the territory okay but
this is like a segment it's just gonna
be trash news okay okay
current event stroke trash news do you
know what's mad sorry
sorry to cut you off this is this is so
crazy how much we kind of think i like
yeah i was thinking about the other day
how
i was thinking about wanting to put a
random
segment in our show because obviously
we originated with ahmadiyasa which is
at the end of the show yeah yeah and
then i've sporadically started to do
this fun fact thing at the beginning was
at the beginning of the show and you
want something i want just something
just to
and it's so crazy but anyway just to
stir the pot fam
listen to this this [ __ ] where is it
so cool title of this article here
yeah police sees 324 000
used contraceptives which were washed
i've seen this and reused i hit my head
i've said it washed and reused no fam
i've seen this
bro they're scooping up old condoms
washing them out re-rolling them
dildo rolling this around actually
literally what's his name phil dave
something phil
from shaky sweaty dave or phil it was
the glasses that said he was sweating
profusely they're putting these doms on
a wooden dildo apparently yeah
re-rolling them up
so they look brand new and they're
sending them back to the general public
terrifying which country is this vietnam
that's terrifying fam 324 thousand
and the lady that runs the whole
shenanigan said that an anonymous donor
was just dropping them off at the door
she doesn't even know who it was he was
just dropping questions asked just bear
naughty condoms who's watching
my first question who's washing them
who's washing these condoms fam slave
traders
themselves you
i don't know what position i have to be
in in life
well how much i don't know how much you
have to pay me beat me or abuse me
to make me wash used condoms out all day
every day
i don't think i think it's more of a
financial thing like i have to do this
financial thing
yeah i i need to i'd rather starve to
death
and there's nothing that could make me
need as soon as you said vietnam like i
didn't
i didn't think because i don't know
anything glamorous in vietnam i've never
been to vietnam but all i know of
vietnam is like
what you see and what you hear like
vietnam war yeah yeah yeah things like
that do you know i mean yeah yeah
vietnam isn't seen deemed as one of the
most illustrious places to visit but
a lot of people do go there when they do
like their little asia tour which i
always look
like vietnam cambodia
so when you said vietnam i just
automatically thought okay
i can kind of see it happening there
yeah do you know what i mean bro i can
see it happening there that's crazy it's
[ __ ] who's the job
financially i think like they they need
to do it they probably need to do it
but like i don't think they repacket
them either though
i think they're just selling the single
rings like that
i don't think they put them in it they
can afford to put it so vacuum seal them
in packets
hold on the picture i've got is just a
minute no no no no no no i've seen that
i've seen that picture because that's
the only picture that's been there yeah
yeah yeah but my assumption is when you
said obviously
that they um just donate them
my assumption is they donated to this
lady in this factory thing
and then she repackages them oh i
thought she's doing it out of a yard
i don't that's my thought i don't know
i've not read into it but that's my
assumption i'm assuming donnie's getting
them from a brothel
i thought that's where my assumption is
that's where he's collecting because
who you can't and he either works in a
sewer
well because you're not supposed to
flush them but everyone flushes them
i've
never flushed a condom have you not no
i've always i've flushed like two in my
life i've never
but then i panicked do you know what i
mean it says do not flush
and then i flushed it i wrapped up in
bare tissue flushed it
and then i'm just like waiting
oh god my floor her floor i don't know
i don't know fam so yeah yeah true
so unless someone's rummaging bins
but if you're rummaging bins there's
certainly something more valuable than
[ __ ] condoms in there
true but maybe they already know that
condom cells are
through the roof people are [ __ ] in
vietnam yeah but who's got that
that's the thing who
who would know that condoms are where
the money are at
someone that's the thing like if you
know there's money in condoms yeah
you have to be in a position in your
life where you don't need to wash out
condoms do you know what i mean
true that makes sense for you to know
the economics behind condoms
you can't be so broke that you need to
be finding loose used condoms on
washington yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense so i'm assuming this is like a
broccoli
yeah i'm assuming this is like someone
who works
or owns a brothel yeah or something yeah
or is the cleaner of a brothel or
something yeah and it's just cleaning
bin bags
full of used johnnies yeah and then just
thinks
[ __ ] it i wonder if someone would want
to if i could donate these
oh that's gross man who's washing that
i'm not washing that
nah what if you need to just not heaps
and heaps of nuts
but what if it's like stockpiled and
then like you just hose it down like
it's it's enough
you don't like what wait did they have
to roll it down on the dildo and then
clean it off or they wrote it down
now i think they wash it out like
individually yeah they have to
because they used to look brand new the
people that are buying them don't know
they're used
so it needs to be squeaky clean you
can't just be washing it down
you have to it has to be you have to get
the you have to get your pinky down and
rim it and
scoop it i'm not doing that with any
man's nut
[ __ ] speaking of not you gagged speaking
of nuts yeah
do you think it's weird or do you think
women think it's weird
that they're okay both
tasting are not and tasting their own
juices yeah but a man will not go near
his own nut
oh i think about that daily dude not
daily obviously
but i think about a lot i think about
that not a lot but every time
every time i probably that's probably
happened to me like where
she's tasting my nut and then maybe i've
eaten her out and then have lipstick or
something like that so she's kind of
tasted her knife stinks there and then
i've
put my finger in my mouth and then she's
tasting her knife yeah yeah and i think
do you ever think i would taste mine
because sometimes i don't feel
like you're crazy how do you like
both the amount of the amount of yes
i've spoken to in the past
that pretty much all of them i guess
yeah um unless that's just never come up
yeah that are wholesomely content with
just tasting their own
stuff that i'm just like
do you understand that i will never
taste mine
do you understand that what
what story type so there was this chick
i was i used to [ __ ] this was years ago
absolute years ago this chick i used to
[ __ ] i had very ad holy because we
didn't
live in the same city and i went to
visit her one time we smashed well right
it was cool
but then there was one time she came to
visit me and
we were [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i
obviously she gave me a head i gave a
head
um i came inside her
and then she said oh i know where this
is going
to say this oh eat me out then kiss me
so i can taste bear in mind
i've just not she knows you've not
inside yeah obviously i've just not
because i've expressed that i've not
changed oh
okay yeah she knows she's always she
knows it's over yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so bear in mind i'm
still inside her oh i just pulled out
yeah
yeah and i'm she's obviously still in
the motion
and she thinks this is not she's
probably she's done this she's clearly
done this before
i i was so revolted
i would be revolted i wanted to headbutt
her
like did you just say no or what i was
saying of course i said
no no because me yeah i struggled to say
in that kind of situation i can't just
say
no no you know i can't i don't know i
struggle with my kid in the mood i
only care about killing the mood yeah
but i had already noticed oh i know this
was
that's the thing you're savage like that
yeah it wasn't a savage thing because
i already knew we both enjoyed the sex
it wasn't the thing where i got an
advantage of anything you know what i
mean yeah
but i just wasn't expecting such thing
from her yeah yeah
and for her to say eat me out and then
lips me so i can taste i'm thinking
who do you think i am that i would want
to taste myself bro
you've obviously done it before yeah
never in a million years did you ever
think that it would work on me
yeah that's disgusting why didn't you
just tell me to like maybe stink see you
and then
i didn't even want to do it i wouldn't i
don't even want to do that but
if it just shows me how freaky she was
yeah of course yeah
and i'm not i'm not
[Laughter]
story time there was a time right i
think i don't know if i think i've told
you this
well i've definitely told you about the
night
so there was a time where me and my
friend my friend or our friend one of
our friends
set up a a two-man thing for me and him
oh and two things yeah
first time i thought to go with fake
tease yeah worst sex of my life
but anyway different that's a different
story already
i already know who this is oh yeah yeah
yeah after i've done writing with this
girl
yeah i'm here with bear arguing in the
other room
they're arguing in the other room never
told me this yeah they're all given
another room i'm thinking what's going
on
so i go out to get some ice or something
just
i get some juice and some ice and i'm
just gonna post that juice
i'm just in my boxers just babes you
want some juice
and i'm just like oh right sweating down
my back and i just wanna pray in it i
want to hear
so i'm there just like sipping slow
thinking what's going on and then my man
comes out
vex boxes just in his briefs and vex
and i was like oh wow go on what's going
on
what are you not secure a man said
brother
she's kicking off because i've nutted
and she wants to
to to finish in it but she's telling me
to go down on her
and i'm like no she
and she comes out like what do you mean
no as well like what do you mean and i'm
like
are you hearing yourself he know i
didn't you right and she was like yeah
and
it was like she wanted to eat his own up
that's just
no never in a million years i wanted to
be like i'm getting [ __ ]
we're going get your [ __ ] we're going we
don't need this
[ __ ] hell but i was like that's so
yeah ladies that's never
ever going to happen is when i get a dm
today like oh my man does it all the
time
i know it's disgusting that's disgusting
there's the thing is what like there's
been times where i've thought ah i wish
i was a bit more
freaky yeah in some aspects yeah yeah
yeah yeah like
i would rather get my ass ate out than
eat my own nut
like i'm not ever doing that i don't
know you know because
what
[Laughter]
what hang on go on go go
go say what the [ __ ] you're gonna say as
soon as you said
i'd rather get my ass ate out i had
completely stopped listening to you and
started thinking about
how i always skip
guys getting that ass ate out by girls
in porn because i hate just i just
yes i mean i didn't hear what you were
saying after that yeah yeah that's what
i said i don't think so yeah so
obviously you were continuing
yeah i hadn't heard a word you said okay
cool yeah because that's what i was
thinking about i
always skip that [ __ ] always they should
delete it from porn
i always skip that [ __ ] i don't want to
see that no i'm not here for that
no one wants to see it i'm not here for
that oh my god i didn't sign up for this
so that's why i obviously didn't hear
the rest of ways yet but yes i would
obviously rather
get that done by to me yeah then you're
out there
of course not of course mixed with so
sorry for [ __ ] shocking
10 seconds before oh cool i just wasn't
listening i know you mean i wasn't
[ __ ] listening
oh do you know what's weird though as
well do you ever think this is like
this is a bit darker but just on the
spectrum
do you think it's weird that we care
well me personally but i feel like this
translates to a lot of people that we
care more
about what your fingers touch than what
your dick touches
oh my god do you know what i mean yes
because you know when you said like
so with the nut thing so if i've not
done a girl
i'm not eating her out afterwards yeah
100 and i'm not fingering her afterwards
okay i'm not fingering with my own in
there that to me is the most revolting
[ __ ]
but i'll happily go round two obviously
yeah
yeah so i'm happy for my dick to be in
there but i'm not putting my [ __ ]
fingers in there that makes it
but your dick is yeah but your dick is
like the most precious thing but it can
it can deal with it you can deal with it
it's made for that
it's made to handle it it is made to
handle that but at the same time it's
weird to think that because your fingers
there's unless you've got cuts yeah
there's no form of penetration there's
no penetration there's nothing that's
coming inside your body
your dick's got a whole all sorts it's
just a messy business
ah and we're just willing to do it again
guilt-free we're screwing everything
you don't even think twice don't you
don't i think i've thought about one
time though
actually okay i think it was a deep knot
i think i [ __ ] up i can't i don't
remember the girl i don't know the
situation but i remember the thought in
my head
yeah i don't remember what sex this was
but i remember a situation
of going round two yeah and for some re
maybe i wasn't too keen on the round two
or whatever okay maybe i was being
coerced
but
maybe i was coerced into this round but
i remember in the back of my head
thinking
oh there's nothing do you know okay
or maybe it slipped in quick maybe it
slipped in easy yeah and i was thinking
like is that me or is that her yeah
jeremy is that
i know what you mean yeah yeah yeah it
was it was great
speak enough i saw you know that um that
insta what's her name
uh that very v brown do you follow her
no she does the [ __ ] funniest let's
get some [ __ ]
she does the deep voice thing i'll show
you one of her videos
you've seen her very lee brown that's a
that's that
that's her the label doesn't ring the
bell let me find her real quick
very very common wi-fi very v brown
she always does the face morphine thing
this yeah i've never seen her
you've never seen that no i'm others are
you for lovers
where why isn't my volume working um bro
she does the funniest
[ __ ] videos
she uploaded the funniest pic the other
day this one
[Laughter]
so for context is it's a [ __ ] meme
that says don't confuse
whap with discharge that's [ __ ]
disgusting
that's [ __ ] disgusting and it reminds
me you know it reminded me of
it reminded me do you ever watch porn no
this is getting grim
before before you say what it reminds me
one can you can i say what it reminded
me of go on
obviously when we did when we did that
episode where
i spoke about or where we discussed
[ __ ] on periods
and obviously in the little skit i said
oh yeah rags i do but etc if you've seen
that episode
you know what i'm talking about someone
dm'd me saying
oh yeah i love to [ __ ] periods it's
10 times wet
just reminded me of what you said say
don't
think it's a rap or whatever don't
confuse whatever
hang on brav i don't even want to say
what i was going to say anymore
a donnie messaged you not a dunny a girl
a girl
message me saying that
i'm trying to think do i find that worse
or not i don't know a girl messaged you
that
said i love [ __ ] on period it's 10
times wetter
oh god oh we're coming oh this is coming
too
because i'm thinking in my head like
right my initial instinct is just pure
yuck yeah
yeah just dirt that that's my initial
instinct is like
there's not wet that's blood like are we
are we accepting that is she
acknowledging that it's blood yeah or
does she
like i'm confused he's got no choice if
when i thought it was a guy i'm 100 like
but he's disgusting because he he likes
blood he's a lubricant
like that's [ __ ] yeah but he doesn't
care yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah so
i thought yuck with a girl i'm thinking
okay well i'd like to think she's got
more etiquette than that
and i'd like to think that she's not
enjoying the fact that her
blood is lubricated this this session
yeah so i'm thinking oh maybe
maybe there is something behind it
because i have her girls are more horny
on their periods
i've heard that as well yeah so maybe
maybe there's a connection between
actual william wetter actually on your
period
or if she's maybe i'm thinking too deep
into it and she's actually talking about
blood
i think she's actually talking about
blood it could be a bit above that's
[ __ ] disgusting
it's this could be a bit off yeah but i
was gonna say continue to what you were
gonna do no i'm not even gonna say one
guy
anymore i'm not gonna say but you
remember i was talking about um
on the episode when i spoke about um
that
that that show uh i may destroy you yes
so now you've seen it right yes
do you remember the bit where she was on
her [ __ ] period and my man was gonna
[ __ ] her
and they put a towel down yes and there
was bare cloths coming out and
everything
and mama was playing with the brushes
and everything i wanted to scream
to the top of my lungs i went to screen
to the top of my lungs there's
yes i remember bravo i remember that was
[ __ ] and when i was watching that i
was thinking
is no one else seen what i'm saying
because i was
i was berated for saying that [ __ ]
periods
and this is this is my introduction this
is what i'm to expect yeah
that's disgusting cause bearcloths
oh it was grim but anyway moving on
let's talk about zana
this is disgusting um have you watched
criminal on netflix no but i feel like
i've seen the trailer you probably have
dopest [ __ ] show is it a series yes
thank the lord i've been looking for a
new series for time
it's quick though from your bank through
it two seasons four episodes each
oh really your bank how many how long
enough i want to say an hour but maybe
maybe shorter oh god it might be about
40. don't tease me
don't tease me
bro it's not long um so basically
it's all set in this uh interrogation
room so it's a police thing
and every episode does not correlate to
the one before oh they're brand new
oh is that like an anthology kind of
thing is that what it's called
i don't know every app doesn't cover it
like a black mirror kind of thing yeah
everyone's this new story
so all it is is a new case new person in
yeah and you
did only in this room only in this room
so you don't know any of the details
until the person walks into this room
and they start the interrogation it's
juicy oh it's
juicy but i'm going to spoil one of the
episodes i have to i have to
do that i have to i have to talk about
it i have to
so if you don't want me to spoil it stop
listening in three two one
here we go so brav this thing so it's
got this episode
the main character's kit harrington okay
[ __ ] from game of thrones
no he looks buff in this episode he
looks clean he's got a suit on
everything he looks
okay okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah
anyway anyway my [ __ ] snow so my man's
in there because what a waste money
what a waste man in the entire t was a
top [ __ ] hole
um anyway slight tangent yeah
i was so gassed even though it was
incest i was so gassed when he [ __ ]
daenerys i was like finally finally
because you know he's loving it yeah oh
oh anyway
she was banging would you uh i hate to
digress
i know people are thinking tell us about
the episode yeah i know i know i want to
digress [ __ ] it it's like
game of thrones chat would you have
carried on [ __ ] and once you knew she
was your auntie
when you know you can die with this
secret
i i think maybe my dick would have
wanted to [ __ ] her again
but my brain would have been telling me
nah that's wrong that's weird that's you
know i mean
yeah maybe like after the first time
yeah after i acknowledge after i'd
[ __ ] and acknowledged that whatever
yeah but wouldn't you like in my head i
would like to justify all of it
i'm probably going to keep [ __ ] her
but i i'm i'm not going to be the kind
of guy who's like man i don't care if
he's marnie
like i'm still got a [ __ ] i would have
been the guy that's like this is wives
tales
yeah this is all wives tales
like i'm hearing it from word of mouth
between this and this and they're saying
that the baby that happened is me but
like
no one's proven it who's to say it was
me anyway
um i would have convinced myself that it
was all wild sales and i would have kept
smashing her
kept smashing yeah yeah yeah
um yeah anyway yeah so this episode
right
so um they get him in the room
and he's kicking is he a suspect he's a
suspect yeah so he's
kitt harrington is getting interrogated
and he's livid
is it sorry to cut you off again is it
american or english english
english i love a good english english
dish when it hits it hits home those bbc
dramas
bro dracula anyway sorry it's quite yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway
go on go on go um so there's
kicking off kicking off yeah he gets in
there he's
vex and he's like why have you taken me
in here all this all this all this yeah
so they get him in there and basically
he's been accused of rape
oh god yeah i know hot topic on this
podcast for some reason yeah yeah
that's the first thing i thought yeah
you spoke about that a lot guys
sorry you keep going i know people are
going to be thinking this is sauce
these man speak about rip too much
anyway so he's been accused
so he goes in there and he's like
whatever i didn't do it i didn't do it i
didn't do it
so they're interviewing him and he's
like so
the the you had to said he raped yes is
a girl that works for him so he works as
an estate agent okay
and he's a big boy in this like big
estate agent firm right okay
so they got he said every friday they go
out for drinks yeah and she's like kind
of new she's only been there for like a
month
yeah so he said the story of how they
were out for drinks having a good time
there's him like two other brayers and
her
and he's like uh obviously she's new so
you i can tell she's trying to prove
that she's like one of the lads in it
that she can go
drink for drink all this stuff it's
getting a bit late so i'm thinking maybe
we should go
so two of the guys leave and he's ready
to go
and he's like cool it was my idea that
everyone goes home
um and yeah it was it was a rap
do you know what i mean um
we're all about to go and she's like nah
nah nah i want to stay i want to stay i
want to stay
um bring this up g
and um he's like all right cool
whatever and this is like he says like
where they live
like that place that they've just left
is their only place that is open yeah so
she says
ah let's go back let's go back to yours
for a few
and he's like all right calm he's gonna
let them know like this is all her idea
not mine etc so they get in the cab
they go back to his and um chat and chat
and chat and she keeps talking about
like how far she wants to go in the
business
and how she wants to learn from him and
she wants to be where he is in a few
years and all this
schmoozy chat so he's like cool cool
they're back go back to his
they're talking talking talking and then
she lips as him
so he lips he says i'm not gonna lie
lipstick back she's attractive
i was down etc but i did not force
nothing
okay so um
they pull up the police pull up a um
a thingy uh a text message okay on the
screen so they've got a tv in the
interrogation room and they're like oh
this is a text message from the girl
to her brethren and it's an angry face
and it says she puts an angry emoji and
the bridge in reply saying what's wrong
and then she put he just kissed me
so they say to him
how do you interpret that text message
and he says
well she's vexed that i just kissed her
i didn't do anything more
and they're saying they're saying the
opposite like
well it seems to us that she's saying
that you just kissed her
off the bat off the bat like she didn't
want it i didn't want it yeah oh
this is yeah there's changes to hold
down yeah yeah so you're saying
obviously it wasn't just a kiss
so other stuff happens so we want to
know what what else happened kind of
thing so he says
oh i decided by that time it's time for
her to leave
okay um so i called her uber and he was
like you can check my account
yeah i called the uber to her house for
her you can check and they're like cool
calm down
we checked yeah but we don't know if
that was after
all this stuff and he says and the uber
got cancelled
by him or by the job it had to be him
but yeah she's there by him
okay she's like yeah you may have called
it the uber but the uber got cancelled
okay and then he was like
yeah that's because um
[Music]
that's because [ __ ]
uh what was it so yeah the uber got
canceled yeah that's because she told me
to cancel it
she said she don't want to go she told
me okay
and they're like okay cool well here's
the situation
her coat that she brought to yours
has traces of your semen on it so
clearly
she was wearing a [ __ ] coat ready to
go when you [ __ ] her
so what we see is potentially you called
her uber or she asked you to call her
uber
you called her an uber you cancelled it
and when she's trying to leave
you raped her and he's like nah
that did not happen that did not happen
he's going nuts like no no no no no
it's not crying to [ __ ] someone with a
[ __ ] coat on yeah like yes she got
her coat on but she's the one telling me
she didn't want to leave yeah
so these men are right cool cool cool
cool
um keep going keep going keep going and
he's like all right cool so like how did
you [ __ ] kind of thing
um and he's like well we just [ __ ] in
like normal [ __ ] he said it was a quick
thing
um it was okay like nothing major it was
just like a
he was like it's one of them trousers
down things it wasn't like explicit yeah
it was just like a trouser thing quick
not kind of thing
so they were like all right calm and
then some guy comes in another police
officer brings in a medical report
yeah so obviously they had to give her a
medical examination and then they put it
down
and man's like the police officer is
like cool so when you were [ __ ] her
and he's looking at pictures in the
medical report
when you're [ __ ] her were you holding
a wrist or anything like that and he was
like
nah i don't think so emma says are you
sure cuz are you sure you weren't
squeezing harris and man's like
nah and then he's like i don't know
like maybe like i don't know and she
like right you into that and he's like
nah i'm actually not into that kind of
thing so
my initial impression to me is like that
i didn't do it but like
maybe i held a wrist like are you
telling me she's got bruised wrists or
something like that he's like don't
don't worry about what i'm telling you
she's got like did you squeeze her wrist
or not did you hold her down by her
wrist
it might be like nah definitely don't
hold her down by the wrist yeah and he's
like so but is it like did you grab the
wrist did you hold it down like well
your story's not adding up kind of thing
and i was like i was drunk i don't
[ __ ] know like ah
so you were drunk so how am i supposed
to believe anything you said like how
and he's a big man i know just because i
was drunk doesn't mean that i didn't
like i don't know the difference between
consensual non-sexual sex for [ __ ]
sake
anyway they're going around in circles
for time about this it's getting
intense through hard it's getting
[ __ ] intense
so they're going around going around
going around
i didn't do it i didn't do it explain
this explain this yeah so then the
lawyer
says oh can we have a quick break and so
the police go outside
and then um the police say oh do you
want to take him outside to have your
break because we can hear you
um if you're going to stay in this room
and the lawyer's like minor you can hear
what i have to say i don't care so the
police leave
give him a break and the lawyer turns to
him and says
right in a minute they're gonna draw us
for the medical report
and it might say that she's got like
internal bruising
and they're gonna try if that happens
they're gonna try and say that you raped
this girl and he's sweating now
and she's like is there gonna say his
internal bruising and man's like
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know how
easily someone bruises like i don't know
and she's and there's dread because the
lawyer's getting upset so the lawyer has
an emotional attachment to this case
yeah so either and not in a good way
like she
she's in a position where you can tell
she's not happy about defending him now
yeah she doesn't want to be defending
him because she actually even the lawyer
thinks he's done it yeah
so um she's like
well what you need to know as your
professional
like lawyer solicitor i need to tell you
that it doesn't actually matter if it
comes out as bruised
yeah or not because if it's bruised you
could have just had rough sex
yeah that doesn't mean you raped her
people do that all the time yeah
if it's not bruised doesn't mean you
didn't rape her yeah
you could have just not [ __ ] the
living [ __ ] out of her while your rape
said you know what i mean yeah so it
doesn't really mean anything
so when they come back and try this
whole song and dance which they will
don't rise to it don't bite just let
them say what they have to say
and we move and that guy's like cool
he's stressed fam
yeah and he said he's thinking i'm going
down yeah so all of this
she's got bruised on the wrist they
didn't even bring up the internal
bruising
if it was there or not we don't know um
so all of this and it's
getting close to the point where they're
about to fully charge my man now yeah
because the interview he's looking it's
looking bad for him yeah he swears
so basically what happened is after all
this occasion
she waited four days to come back in and
say
our um he raped me kind of thing okay
so his like defense is like if i raped
her surely she would have just gone
straight from my yard to the police if
that's what would happen yeah and
they're like well actually no in a lot
of cases it doesn't happen like that
so we can't that's a terrible defense
like you can't use that kind of thing
and he's all right cool and then they
said to him why do you think she waited
four days
and man's like right i don't want to be
that guy yeah
but on the monday we like i [ __ ] her
on the saturday on the monday
she interviewed for a job a new job a
higher position job that she was
never gonna get yeah never gonna get and
i think the owner now i'm thinking about
it i think the only reason she [ __ ] me
is because she thought it would make it
easier for her to get that job because
all she kept talking about was promotion
this promotion that
oh yeah i forget that she works for him
yeah
yeah she was like the whole night she
would talk about promotion this
promotion that on the monday she
interviewed for a job that she was never
going to get
on tuesday she found out she didn't get
it maybe she was mad and maybe that's
why on wednesday thursday she's coming
separately saying that i raped her
i don't want to be the guy that says
that kind of stuff
but that's changed the whole dynamic of
the show but that might have been the
case
these men are about to brush it under
the rug
just like shut the [ __ ] up that never
happened yeah you raped this [ __ ]
just as we're getting to that point
another police officer that's
in like the back room behind the mirror
is doing research
and he pulls up there he has to pull up
the girl's phone records and stuff
and then there's a random text in there
that says um
bungalow part two question mark and
that's what the rate
the girl who got raped she sent that to
her mate
and said bungalow part two so my man's
like
what's this bungalow part two thing like
it's random they're talking about all
this sex [ __ ]
and now they're talking about bungalow
part two
well no she says didn't get the job
that's what it was after she interviewed
him together job she messaged her and
said didn't get the job
bungalow part two and then the man's
like
what's she on about yeah bungalow part
two yeah
they bring up bank records and stuff
like that
so they come back in
and the guy calls the the other police
officers back in the room and says i
need to talk to you
so what's going on is that ah i just
came across this bungalow part two thing
um i've looked into it and the bredrin
who she's talking to i looked into her
bank records
and i looked at her linkedin profile and
last year
she was working for a separate company
for a month
she applied for a bigger position didn't
get it
accused one of the execs of raping her
and they paid her a settlement and with
that settlement
her and this girl that's been raped went
to south africa
and stayed in a bungalow
and that's where she's coming up with
this bungalow tooting that's why she
applied for a higher job
didn't get it now she thinks if she
accuses my man of raping her
she's going to get a settlement
fam blows the case wide open
blows the case wide open so they go back
in
they don't tell jon snow any of this
john they don't tell jon snow any of
this he's sweating
he's sweating he's so stressed
so he goes in there they go in there
like cool well um
we're gonna terminate the interview now
and he's like
what what does that mean yeah like are
you taking me in while we go yeah yeah
yeah
and they're like oh you can go home and
he's like
i'm confused what do you mean i can go
home and then donny's like well don't
you want to go home
he's like of course i want to [ __ ] go
home but you dragged me
from work yeah to here saying i've raped
someone
and now five hours later you're telling
me i could just [ __ ] off home like what
does this mean
kind of thing and it's like oh well um
we don't have enough evidence to convict
you
so we have no choice but to let you go
and he's like
cool so what does this mean and the guy
the
office is getting angry now and he's
like what do you mean what does this
mean
fam the most amazing the thing this show
does so well
is they encapsulate current times okay
so
they really encapsulate even though it's
a police show yeah they encapsulate
people's
frustration with the the police and the
current climate yeah
so he goes like i just want to talk to
you later and the police officer is
trying to leave the room and he's like
no no no like i need to talk to you kind
of thing
yeah and then like get security in here
like this guy seems like he's gonna get
irate
and he's like just he's that big man i
gave you five hours of my time
just give me five minutes so the police
officer's like all right cool man
i'll give you five minutes so what the
[ __ ] do you want to say and my man said
you dragged me out of my place of work
in front of clients colleagues
and friends under the premise
that i've raped someone you told
everyone
that i've been accused of raped and you
arrested me and dragged me here
and now you're telling me to just rock
up back to work tomorrow
la di da he's a big man
like i need a signed statement or
something to say that i did not do this
and this is a whole mistake
and the police officer's like it doesn't
work like that brav like you were
accused
we haven't got enough evidence to do it
doesn't mean you didn't do it
go [ __ ] off kind of thing like what more
do you want and then my man says cool
last year he's at my mind he said my mom
and my dad own a student uh flat okay
like norwich or something last year the
police
raided the flat on a drug search thing
yeah they
[ __ ] up the yard on their raid yeah
and once they were done they didn't find
nothing
so they paid and replaced everything
and my mom said when she went back in
there on the monday it was
better looking than it ever was okay
and the um they just put everything back
the way it was
and the police officers like yeah
because she was inconvenienced and man
was like
i was [ __ ] inconvenienced don just
because i didn't rape her
being accused in this day and age that's
not enough yeah
not getting charged is not enough if i
want to keep my job
and keep my friends and keep my
livelihood you need to write something
on a piece of paper or br bring me back
to work tomorrow
you come in to work with me tomorrow and
tell everyone i didn't do it
no [ __ ] basically says that's your
business whatever happens to you now
is your business a man has man goes mad
he gets dragged out by security he gets
dragged out of the room
and i was thinking bro that's so
accurate
like you can't just get arrested in your
place of work and be expected to walk up
there tonight yeah the next day
with people not asking you questions you
can't keep your job you cannot keep
yourself
you can't keep it you don't get to keep
your job i'm going to keep my job
if someone came into my work and said
we're accusing you of rape we're
arresting you on the premise that you've
raped someone
who works here and dragging me out in
front of everyone
and i'm like i didn't do it yes
or no stop fam bear man in there and
you're like i didn't do it
get off me i didn't do it and you look
at your boss and she's like
and you're like i promise i didn't do it
you can't go back in there tomorrow
anything you do or say
anything you do or say nah
you're sad regardless if you didn't do
it you're sacked you're the hot topic
now
you can't get hired anywhere of course
not yeah
you need references you need references
look at the house fam his life is ruined
because this one yacht said he did
something that he didn't do
these streets are unforgiving the game
is the game is the game
that game's dirty i know i know that's
foul play that's why i don't want to be
anyone's boss
that's foul play fam
just so my girl can see bungalow tutu
bungalow part two how nice was this
bungalow
it must have been banging fam
couldn't believe it my my man's life was
ruined
ruined i would have banged her in her
face the next day
at work i'm finding out where she lives
i'm finding out where she lives
no one can stop me no one can stop i'm
finding out where the [ __ ] she is
it's tough out here but yeah ma'am do
you want to do one mighty [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] hmm
there's um you've already answered this
one yeah yeah yeah
when it came mean you answered it over
dm this is uh this is this one was sent
to us
okay okay okay and you answered it but
i'm not letting this one slide
okay there's no why there's no way when
i saw because of my
response no nothing to do with you oh
you got me worried
sorry sorry sorry yeah there's no way
i'm letting this one just slide into the
bushes okay
you know i mean yeah yeah yeah no way
cool
and just just just yeah like this girl's
a lovely girl
this girl's a lovely girl but this is
this is not okay
she's a lovely sweet woman but this
can't run
so i'm either [ __ ]
slept with this guy a couple
uh every time after he would ask me for
money
and i wouldn't give it to him but then
he would try to trash my name to our
mutual friends
but then i found out he had a girlfriend
so i filmed
him eating me out and then sent it to
her
captioning teach teaching your man some
new tricks
you're welcome come collect him in 20
minutes
a different one my ex-girlfriend
sent me a video of her [ __ ] her new
man
so i sent it to her dad
i know i'm the [ __ ] for the second
one but i think it's funny
fam when i read this i was like
oh my god i couldn't reply that's why
you did it i couldn't reply
i was like oh my good god that is
the most disrespectful thing i've ever
heard right let's take the first one
so the first one she's [ __ ] a guy
every time they [ __ ] he asks for money
she says no i'm assuming they've got
mutual friends and he tries to trash her
yeah yeah yeah which makes zero sense
she found out he had a girlfriend so
next time mama's eating [ __ ]
she recorded it and sent it to the
girlfriend that's treacherous
femme all right cool let me break it
down from my perspective first
first of all i don't know why he's
asking for money
that doesn't make any it doesn't make
any considering they're in the same
group
that doesn't make i'd ask my girl for
money if i've got a girlfriend rather
than asking the thing i'm [ __ ] on the
side for money
who why are you [ __ ] the guy that's
asking for money first and foremost
we've had this discussion before why are
you [ __ ] me if i don't know
if i've got money from anyway
why are you asking from who asked for
money in this day and age
anyway so [ __ ] the guy's asking for
money
you say no he trashes your name whatever
and
i don't know how he has a premise to
trash anyone's name asking for money
yeah yeah
from anyone yeah yeah it's like it
doesn't balance it doesn't i don't what
are you saying
do your bedrooms about like oh yeah i
was liking this girl and like
she wouldn't run me pee so now she's a
hoe she's a hoe because i [ __ ] her and
she wouldn't give me anyway
um which one's one so you found out he
had a girlfriend regardless of him
trashing your name and all this stuff he
found out he had a girlfriend so you let
him eat puss
you didn't even lock it off he let him
run through eat puss
recorded him doing it first of all how
did you get away with that
he must have been up because you can't
get away with that so they must have
been doing it before if i'm
if i'm guzzling and then i hate see your
phone come out
i'm swinging for you if i see a bright
light in the mist
because when i'm eating prom i'm i'm
engulfed you know what i mean
we know we know if i see like a bright
light in my top left my top right
i think what's what's that you know
where crack or dawn what's that i will
perk up like a dog fam you know when a
dog hears a burglar
i will perk up and say what's that i
would draw from my boss will swing
i'll climb up her naked body give me the
phone
you're not recording me you're not
recording me
but my arse up nah cheeks
cheeks glistening in the sun nah
and she starts from the crack down
and my hips are wiggling
never in a million years nah i'll fight
you
i will fight you um run me that phone
now
and then you know that's the thing that
that's the bit that bit irked me yeah
because it did she didn't need to know
that
regardless if this guy's trash and all
that stuff if you're gonna record him
and threaten him with anyone yeah you
don't need to threaten him with an
innocent bystander yeah just friend him
threaten him and say bro i'm gonna put
this on instagram yeah this is going to
start anywhere yeah don't send it to his
[ __ ] girlfriend yeah
i don't remember why does she have to
deal with that
imagine a guy sending a video of your
girl sucking him off
i don't need that's fight talk
that's fight talk this has nothing to do
with my girl anymore
do i mean as it's between me and you
why are you trying to ruin my life what
did i do to you
you're an [ __ ] biggest [ __ ] thing
you can do
you [ __ ] this girl's life up
so what's your she had to see her own
man on all fours
for what a little jokey joke
oh a little giggle
nah nah that's out of order
i'm running to you odd if you say come
collect them in 20 minutes cool postcode
question mark fam bear question mark
question yeah
location where you at share that share
your location then
i'll come i'll come collect him i'm
rocking you both i'm burning the yard to
the ground you think i won't
i'll burn the yard to the ground we're
both human in there
you think i won't you sound like such
oh [ __ ] it that's jokes i'll tell her
talk that talk
i'll burn your house down nah
my loved one my loved one in my own
nah you won't have a yard tomorrow
that's fine
you haven't got a yard anymore that's
what i'm replying
come collect your mind in 20 minutes you
haven't got a yeah what are you on about
and then you'll smell smoke
enjoy that nut because it's going to be
your last your last
oh your sniff smoke from then what was
what was the second one she said
second one is she's got an ex-girlfriend
i'm assuming she's bi
she's an ex-girlfriend who sent her a
video of her getting [ __ ] by her new
man
oh jesus what's going on in this circle
record everybody everyone's recording
everything
who's more embarrassed fam she was
probably the girlfriend
ah [ __ ] hell what's going on what's
all these video things cuz
can't anyone just have consensus reply
oh you
were oh i didn't read the whole reply
all i saw was wow
um right in the first one i need to
fight i need to see it as well
he said firstly yeah lol wow yeah
in the first one why the [ __ ] was he
asking you for money heading please
that's changed the whole game no i get
into the dot from day one
really from day one i didn't know it was
did you connect the dots
no sporting i connected from day one
anyways
i was gonna shoot over a dm like tap tap
tap
you must have thought i forgot nah
yeah so read it out again for the fans
that's [ __ ] hello cool so
i never knew what's her your reply
firstly
wow in the first one why the [ __ ] was he
asking you for money
did he always have to travel to get to
yours and not know how to get back
or is he just casually asking for money
all the time
[Laughter]
that's too funny that's too funny
oh and then you followed up with that's
weird as [ __ ]
the filming is sending to his girl is
hella peak
but he had a girl so the game is well
and truly the game
the second one 100 100 you're the
[ __ ] no question
ah you sweep
me and then she said nah me and him to
three minutes apart
why is he asking for money oh
i don't get it i don't know why he's
asking for money i don't know why he's
asking for [ __ ] money
that's neither here nor there yeah
oh jesus why are you sending to my
girl's dad
why she sent her getting pike to you i
don't know
i don't know i don't
because it's like it's not even like
she's a guy yeah
so she's not even it's not even like
she's sending her videos so
like say she hates her yeah say it was a
guy yeah and she hates her ex
yeah yeah so she recorded next man
[ __ ] around and said this is what
yeah yeah yeah
i don't condone that but at least that
makes it more plausible
this doesn't make any sense it's
backwards
so yeah but still firm that
do whatever like do whatever you need to
do yeah don't send it to her [ __ ] dad
fam that's
that's her dad dad that's crossing not
even her mom her dad
that's crossing the line if anyone sends
me a video of my daughter getting
backshoted
guards are burning fan
everyone's yard is burning but man are
smelling smoke
everyone's yard is burning no that's
that's this uh
that's two disrespects too far i can't
condone that kind of behavior
too far it's like how does that respond
with the consequences because i am going
to kill you i have to kill you now
i can't see you anymore i can't see you
on road anymore that's the thing if i'm
the dad as well like obviously yeah
rags like oh my daughter's
ex has just sent me a text like what's
this about and i open it and it's my
daughter get [ __ ] by some random guy
postcode i'm replying please post your
question mark yeah hug your mum because
this is the last time
fam your yard's about to burn
calm i'm just replying calm video pops
through
you see the little scene thing scene
calm calm say less
fam if i was the bra
my eyes would have widened mid-back shot
i would have been petrified
calm nah nah nah
but yeah if i'm the whole thing is long
the whole thing yeah that's that's
all that is our soul behavior i didn't
know it was her
i didn't know it was her that sent it to
us it was g
you got swindled you got swindled
[Laughter]
bless her that's a thing she's a lovely
girl she is a lover i was thinking how
do you know she's a lovely girl yeah
how do you know because obviously i
i see the the the messages as well blah
blah blah and i was thinking how do you
know because i don't know who you're
talking about then i read the name i was
like oh [ __ ]
makes sense that's um that's that's
uncalled for
very uncomfortable although that's
uncalled for this this circle you've got
this these mutuals this is you need to
disconnect from all of them from all of
that you need a you need something
different you need a fresh start
because you've got a bright future and
these men are holding you back
because this lot yeah all this video
team this video thing is killing my
people because
no one's draws him for a phone at me
i'll kick it
mid sex mid fellatio well i'm doing
favors
tongue tongue favors and you're yeah
just
oh
i'm throwing out three gogs and you want
to record man nah
the audacity i don't care if i've got a
girl i'll tell him i don't care
it's not okay what you've done is not
okay
if i'm a cheat that's in my own right
yeah i had to deal with that in my own
life yeah yeah
what are you trying to do what are you
trying to do you're just [ __ ] up
everything
ah oh [ __ ] it but yeah anyway rap
wrap next week you